今日は実験的な
感じで行きたいんだよ
あんまり多くは語りません
コーラにメントスを入れると爆発するのって知ってますよねっ
今日はそれを利用した応用的な
実験をしたいと思う
まずですねもう普通にコーラがあると
[音楽]
ぼくのかんがえたですよ麺とそうここに家れたんですか
を入れると反応したら爆発するのはみなしていると思うんですけど
ここでしか爆発しないと思うんですよ濃いレッド9コーラだけが反応して
高
なーんてなるだけだと思ったここに入れてここだけ反応してたら一番多くまで
メントスが届くようなベントローのメントスのような年どうぞ
すれば
こう全部入った瞬間この子ら全部が反応して
ef けど分者でくらいのバカ強くが
手に入ると思ったんでん
メントスを使っていっ
ロンギヌスの槍を作ろうとが出た瞬間も低低レネーデレて出るッスからね
すごいねサードインパクトで今日は起こそうと思います
[音楽]
ウール
ん
持った
mar ん
ポップン
[音楽]
うんん
うん
うううう
ていた
par ん
ません
みんなあーを作った
goo
ん
[音楽]
goo
ああああああ
ません
あーん
ううううん
ん
me
バーンん
グーン
goo
[音楽]
夏バテっ
せませ味わえませんやはり本当にやつで火傷するレベルだわてが焼けました
ああああああ
me
ani
[音楽]
んまぁ
ん
r
pa ん
くそっ
20分
ブーブー
ん
さあ皆さんやってまいりました
なんとかカーンと感度もツクッター
ロンギヌスの槍なんですけど
さあここはスタまで行くとねー
どんなね
仕入れる
えっ
そう
じゃあああああ
ちょっとすーっちょっと
うわぁ
ああああああああ
den ん
じゃあ
ちょっっ
ん